こんにちははじめしゃちょーです最近あっ
た台風15号の被害についてのお話です
えー僕も死んでいます静岡県の静岡市です
ね
静岡市でかなり大きな被害があったと
聞いております
僕が住んでいる
周りでも結構ひどくてその
台風がちょうど来ていた日
9月の25日ですね
9月25日の夕方からもうすごい雨が降っ
てて本当に
ここを数年に見たことないくらいすごいね
降っててもう車乗ってても前は見えないし
水はもう
道路すごい溢れてるしでその日東京行く
予定だったんですけどももう新幹線ももう
雨の影響で止まっててその日は
新幹線が結局運休だったということで駅
行ってもかなり大勢の方が
困っていらっしゃったもう居場所が行き
場所がなかったりとか行くだったはずの
いけないとかですごい困っていた方が
たくさん多い印象を受けましたほんと
すごかったです実際にその被害があった
街にいたので5秒ぐらい雨に当たったら
もう全部塗れるぐらいの
すごい勢いの水でしたで特に被害があった
のが静岡市っていろんな区があるんです
けども
清水区清水っていうところがすごいあの
被害が大きかったという話を聞いており
ます
世界の画像とかTwitterとかで見る
んですけども中にはやっぱフェイク
ニュースがあったりだとか確実な情報信憑
性が薄い情報があって安易に行動しちゃ
いけないと思ってちょっと
確実な情報をもとに今回行動させて
いただいておりますので僕言うことは基本
的にあの裏取りできてるので安心して聞い
てくださいで結構その
被害が大きかった
清水に住んでいる
友達から
画像だったり動画を頂いたんですけれども
ちょっと
ご覧くださいはいこれが
公園ですねその
浸水川がもう溢れちゃってて
家の1階とか全部水浸しになっちゃうん
ですよでそういう新鮮の水って下水の水が
上がったりとかしててもう本当に汚いん
ですよ
共通行けないレベルの汚さなのでもうその
水に触れてしまった家具とかは全部もう
使えなくなってしまうということでかなり
たくさん廃棄されてますねこれ排気なのか
な家具がたくさん置かれてますねでこれが
多分翌日かな
すごいなもう町が水で
浸ってますこれも
結局下水が混ざってるのでこの水が引けば
いいって話じゃないんですよ全部汚染され
てるんで引いた後もかなりそのバイキン
だったりとか衛生的に非常にやばいんです
よ
僕はそんな詳しくはないですけどこれ実際
にその友達の家ですね匠副社長昔動画撮っ
てた
仲間のおばあちゃんのお家なのかなおじ
ちゃんおばあちゃんのお家かなもう濡れて
ますね家具が
うーんこれ水がねやっぱりその
雨水とかと話が違うっていうのが本当に
すごい
相当復帰するのが大変だなと思って見て
おりました女性の僕ネット基本的に信じて
ないんでこれこういう
ちゃんとしたリアルな友達から送られて
ないと全部信じないんで確実にこういう
状況が今
僕が住んでいる静岡の街で起きていますで
もっとやばいのがね男性が起きてるらしい
んですよ水が出ないらしくていや相当影響
がでかかったのかなはいこれは動画ですね
いや
すげーな
うーんやっぱ
これ本当に
じいちゃんおじいちゃん当たってるという
状況が続いています男性もまだ続くみたい
ですねしばらくあれだけねあれだけ申請し
てかなり汚いお水が出てきてここからの
復旧がかなり大変だなと僕思ってますでえ
台風15号により被害の対応静岡県の
対応はえっと動画の概要欄にリンクの載せ
ておきますネットの情報かなり色々出て
ます個人で発信されるのも大事だと思うん
ですけどもやっぱりどうしても信憑性が裏
が取れないので逆に不安になっちゃう人も
いると思いますのでぜひ確実な情報だけを
仕入れてくださいこっちのホームページの
URLは静岡県のホームページです確実な
情報こちらに載っておりますので被害に
遭われた方こちらから情報を仕入れて
くださいそしてですねすでに
静岡県日本赤十字社
静岡県支部社会福祉法人静岡県共同募金会
の窓口で義援金の募集を始めております
左目の台風15号で
被害
暴れた地域の復旧を心から願っております
僕にできることは本当確実な情報を発信
することとこの大会の被害に暴れた地域に
対しての
現金300万円出させていただきました
少しでも役に立てればなと思っております
なとボランティア情報も静岡市から出て
ますね被災された方の連絡先そして
ボランティア活動を希望される方の
連絡先もありますこちらも是非協力して
くださる方がいらっしゃいましたらサイト
の方チェックしていただけると助かります
いや
実際にその
被害があった町に行ったんですけど
ちょっとすごかったなー新幹線止まる時点
でちょっと怪しいなと思ったんですけど
ちょっと想像以上の被害でしたね俺が住ん
でる隣の町だな清水の方が本当に被害が
びっくりするぐらい出てるみたいで腹筋を
ただその男性が治って水が元にいました
水が引いてあの良くなりましたとかじゃ
なくていいがもう壊滅的に
影響を受けた方とかなんか本当に取り返し
のつかないような被害を受けている方も
いらっしゃいますどっちかというとこの後
が大事になると思いますのでちょっとその
町に住むものとしてできることをしたいと
思いましたぜひ
ご協力してください方はよろしくお願いし
ますはいもう本当に皆さんとか災害とか
台風とかそういうのはどうしようもないの
で気をつけて過ごすしかないと思います
ぜひあの
命だけは気をつけてくださいで